on police have shot dead a man in his
20s after a car chase ended in south
london officers say they were pursuing a
suspect vehicle last night police
apparently deliberately collided with
the car to force it to stop bringing the
pursuit to an end in stretching hill
residents reported hearing gunshots and
a police helicopter in the sky above
there's a massive bang that thought a
neighbor's
roof had fallen off or something it's a
real that
i think it was like boom like something
that maybe it bounced to us and i looked
out the back window to see someone had
fallen and straight away i didn't really
notice it before but straight away i
could hear the helicopter very close in
the air and that's not terribly unusual
for around here but it suddenly was like
you know just felt more intense but it's
usually very fairly calm around here so
it's a bit bit of a shock yeah
well our crime correspondent martin
brunton joins me now live martin what
more details have you got about the
pursuits and the incident itself
well the
police watchdog the independent office
for police conduct has taken over
this investigation and their
investigators have been here
since last night working through the
night probably about to hand over to a
new team and the kind of thing they're
trying to establish is you know vital
things like was there a weapon a
non-police weapon
retrieved from the scene what was the
reason for the police pursuit those are
the vital questions
that will be asked how many officers
were involved how many shots were fired
and trying to establish as closely as
they can
the exact circumstances and what
prompted
the shooting were any shots fired at the
police now
i don't have answers to any of those and
i think at this stage investigators
aren't absolutely clear they will have
got
last night's initial statements very
brief statements from the officers
involved
but it may take some longer time to
establish exactly what happened
the facts according to the police are
that this happened just before 10
o'clock last night police had pursued
a vehicle from lambeth so sounds as
though it was heading south probably
hadn't traveled very far
they came to this road here
police rammed the car or um
not clear how violent that was
but they brought it to a halt
according to witnesses
the officers got out asked the driver to
get out
and
according to another witness the car
moved towards the police cars and then a
shot or shots were fired
there's no official identification of
the man who died but there is a name on
the street
friends of the man they think was the
victim here who died have been talking
about their um how distraught they are
how they recognized him from the car
number plate the car still here
they say he was on his way to see
friends and they are like his family
completely puzzled and shocked about
what happened here last night